The joe rogan experience.
Happy Canadian thanksgiving by the way.
Thank you.
Oh,
powerful Canadian thanksgiving.
It is a very powerful and uh,
interchangeable Columbus Day of it.
Only because sometimes this is the 12 sometimes it's a real change.
Oh,
so today is or isn't it?
Is,
it is.
You know how this one's fluid,
like President Day,
you know,
kids don't get that off school anymore.
No,
not funny.
When we were talking about it today,
like yeah,
cause they realize Columbus was kind of a mass murderer.
No holidays changed more in ethos from the time we were a little to now.
Well like Santa Claus didn't become a fucking housebreaking sexual violator.
Yeah,
you're right.
At first it was Columbus discovered America with the Santa Maria and the Pinto,
Anna Nina.
And then it was,
oh,
he never really got to America.
He was in The Bahamas or some shit.
And then it got to,
he's a murderer and just dashing babies' heads on rocks and stories of the year.
And they would force people to get,
bring them back gold and they would have to bring like whatever they weighed and
gold every week.
And if they didn't,
they'd cut one of their arms off.
Oh yeah.
So they do it to a couple people.
They cut their arm off and everyone's screaming.
And so the rest of them just scramble and go and get that gold.
Like they,
they there.
Do you remember the last time I was on,
we talked about Columbus cause you called him an original gangster.
He really was.
Well I think everybody was gangster back then.
Crown couldn't wait.
It was when he got back after the first one.
It took a long time.
The other guy who hated him,
who was also co captain of the expedition died for much to his good fortune.
He was in another boat,
isn't the Nina and uh,
so Columbus got back after much ado.
Yeah.
Did you go to Portugal?
He almost crashed.
Landed the whole fucking enchilada.
When he finally got to Ferdinand and Isabella,
he had enough stuff with him from that first journey.
And by the way,
he left like 40 guys there because the Santa Maria ran aground and there was
fucking scuppered.
So he just left a bunch of fucking guys in the Caribbean.
And they died.
They got in fights with the Indians and died when he got back to Spain and
finally,
finally got to front in front of the king and Queen.
He had a cut,
you know,
eight,
10 Indians and some parents and some gold and some native shit.
And they went,
you know,
their minds are blown.
No one knew there was another world right now.
I mean,
people knew there was another world,
but they didn't know that you could go find a new one like that.
Like he came back with people from another place who spoke Airwalk and had
fucking monkeys.
What the fuck is this?
Here's a bunch of men,
10 times more money,
a bunch more boats.
The second expedition was hugely funded.
Anyone ever with horses cannons,
the whole fucking and shit.
Wow.
The first one was like,
when you send your friend a fucking home depot,
you're,
here's my car.
Don't use the blinker.
You know?
Right.
He barely made it there in backed on the first one and yes,
he did do all those horrible things to the Indians.
He was no notion of them as people.
He was a strict Catholic.
He believed that he had been singled out by God.
Just the idea of custody peoples' arms off cause they didn't bring enough and
doing it in front
of their family.
If he didn't produce precious goods for the Spanish crown,
that he wasn't going to keep getting funded.
When he went back and that was the driving to keep going and pushing through to
Asia was what he was after to find China cause he knew there'd be ivory and
pearls and all that Shite toggle.
But look what he look at it on the other hand,
within 20 or 30 years of Columbus,
now they're in Mexico and within another hundred years without the largest
silver mine in the world,
that giant mountain of silver that all of the silver of Asia for 400 years came
from because of the Spanish trade routes between China and shit.
They reduced a mountain of silver in Mexico and some in South America too.
And use the Indians to fucking do it on the mountain of silver.
I mean,
there's a book called 1493,
uh,
Charles Mann,
well,
new all using Columbus is the line of demarcation for everything.
There's a book called 1491 and a book called 1492 and a vehicle because he's the
first contact,
you know,
between west and east or between,
between the Americas and you and the old world.
And uh,
on his boat he had,
he was Italian,
he had Portuguese,
there was some Spanish,
there was some,
generally is probably a couple of Venetians.
Uh,
by the time Cortez,
when Cortez came over,
which is what,
30 years after,
there was women conquistadores on his boat,
women come case dad.
There was about two or three conquistadores in his book.
Why they don't tell you all the fun stuff in the game of Thrones.
Exactly.
Big giant warrior.
Imagine what a bad acid or you had to be to be on that fucking mission.
And Cortez burned the boats and took a vote with everybody and said,
you want to go back or not?
And they were like,
he goes,
okay,
this is how it's going to go.
We know where the capital of the [inaudible],
this is our mission and let's look,
and they got all the Indians along the way and that's how they did it.
And they burned the boats.
They couldn't go back.
Yeah.
But according to one book I read by Bernal Diaz,
who was the last survivor of that mission,
he landed up in like Honduras or whatever,
the little ranch when he was old.
He writes the forward,
I'm old and I'm blind now,
but I'm going to tell you what the fuck happened when on the mission with Cortez
and he'd been on a previous one with another conquistador and then he says,
he didn't just say we're burning the boats.
We took a vote.
Whoa.
Captain General Cortez said to the boys,
parrot is you can go back to Cuba where they were living or you can go back to
span where you got nothing horsch gold and fucking glory and to State Lawn and
you may die and they may eat.
You eat your heart out.
It's so such an ability to take risks back then.
It's pretty extraordinary.
I mean the genocide and the Indians is of course the disgusting part.
But I mean the Aztecs did have a organized army and you know,
it wasn't,
it wasn't a hundred Spanish guys.
They had tens of thousands of Indians in their army when they finally laid the
big battle out,
Columbus on the other hand just Kinda maraud around the Caribbean and tried to
get these poor Indians who had no gold to give him gold and he was in the wrong
country.
Man.
You know America's work oldest,
well,
didn't they give him something at some point in time they get a little baubles
but there's bottles had come from the mainland or you know,
had been traveled across the Caribbean or from South America where there was
stuff and that they didn't have any gold there.
So they were weighing little earrings and nose rings and Shit and he'd be like,
that was it though.
Total focus and they couldn't understand exterior given him chicks and food and
like,
well,
what else do you want?
We have,
but you don't have fucking the gold.
And why is the golden boy you,
it's not important to us.
They were like,
and he just went as soon as he saw any goal.
That was the end of that.
We have,
how do they have this?
Obviously they have that one account from Cortez you were talking about from one
of the people that,
oh,
there's loads of accounts of Cortez cause there's fryers,
the row.
How do they have these accounts?
Oh,
Columbus wrote a diary and a guy's on his ship wrote diaries and a,
there's a famous uh,
trees to as the,
the sort of the conscience of the new world who decried the genocide against the
Indians from the very beginning.
And the Spanish kept meticulous records and there's a giant library in Seville
called the library of the indies where all of the Caucasians Adores fucking
documents are collated and captain.
So there's,
that's awesome.
There are legal society.
So you brought a priest with you.
You bought a notary with you,
you brought lawyers with you,
you brought generals with you.
You brought a doctor,
you wrote shit down.
You fucking,
when you took over a town,
you wrote a sign and posted a crucifix sense.
So how much did you agree to the Indians who can't understand you,
that you are taking over their town in the name of the King of Spain and Chen?
How much bullshit,
all of that.
I mean,
you know,
so when,
when they would tell their version of the events,
how much of it was bullshit histories all spinning,
isn't it?
I don't think all of it's bullshit because there's a lot of real also Indians
wrote accounts later who lurks within a generation.
Obviously there's Mexicans,
which are the marriage of Indians and,
and Spanish,
right?
And uh,
within a generation,
all of the Aztec noble is of which there were lots and all the nobles in Mexico
from the Indian tribes married into rich,
you know,
married into Spanish family.
So they were raised as rich people who spoke Spanish now and they were able to
tell their stories as well.
There's a lot of first person accounts by the explorers.
Cabeza de Vaca kept a diary in,
I mean Columbus is is great because it's so self serving,
you know,
he'll knits whole portions of the journey and he doesn't mention some of the
ratty shitty did and the radish,
it was all ratted out by priests,
right?
Yeah.
And then later expeditions within by the second expedition,
guys were mutinying on him and and fucking going back to Spain and ratting on
him that he was a terrible and competent fucking commander and that he had,
once they got on land,
he was useless and he didn't know how to handle it.
The Indians and there was always in her violence with the cruise killing each
other and choosing sides and hiding on different parts of the island from each
other and not doing what he asked him to do.
He was a terrible commander on the sea.
The greatest thing you can say about Columbus's,
he's an extraordinary navigator.
He knew that there was going to be a trade wind and he caught it.
Having had some of that knowledge.
He knew that if he went down and got it,
he could come and get one back.
And I think he guessed that he surmised lottery knew from other sailors and shit
that you wouldn't actually get lost in die.
You could come back to Europe from wherever you were going in Asia.
And he didn't have a,
a telescope.
This is previous to the telescope.
So He is dead reckoning and it was terrible with instruments.
Like he had an astro lab and he had a sexton but he couldn't fucking use them
very well.
So all of his reckonings in the book,
Andy kept two separate notebooks.
One with his navigational charts and another with fake ones in case anybody
caught him cause he didn't want anybody copying is root cause he thought he was
going to have the monopoly on going to the new world.
So within of course,
20 years,
within,
within four years,
there's a whole bunch of other Spanish vowels coming over and you know,
within 10 years it's all over those growing levels.
So when he first starts writing it down,
you said that he's writing,
he's not using instruments.
He,
he could,
he had instruments,
they're crappy.
They didn't have any idea of longitude.
Right.
Longitude was kind of a free flowing affair.
If you had shit you could focus on like stars or bodies of our islands or
whatever the you could now the gate,
which is why those maps of the world always seemed so small right from then.
Um,
so he had to recommend by currents and winds and the color of the water,
how the water,
the salinity of the water tested.
They had a rope with thumbs on it,
marked in knots and that take soundings to see how fucking deep the sea was.
And all of a sudden when they got near and the crew was having a heart attack,
cause they'd been out for a couple months and it's true.
The crew was like,
hey,
we're going to die.
And he said,
calm the fuck down.
And the next day,
uh,
clearly something a human had made,
like a carved paddle hit the boat and they pulled it out.
And what,
you know,
there's something over there and then the next day a bunch of branches and shit
and then birds and when there's birds and branches,
there's fucking islands and they knew.
Then the men started to get hip to the fact that he wasn't wrong.
There was something over there.
And then of course he,
he said whoever sees the island first gets a prize and the guy in the middle of
the night saw the lights and he said when they got up in the day,
I saw him last night.
Oh,
shouted his crew.
So why not her loved him.
What lights did he see?
Fires to?
Indians were burning.
Oh Wow.
Fascinating.
I know,
right.
That's amazing.
It is.
It's really weird to think of their gear navies.
No rifles on the first expedition.
Maybe a couple of,
not rifles like Arca buses that you lit a fuse and put it in a breach and you
know,
he had to pack it down,
pack it down with the ball.
A lot of crossbows,
a few crossbows that was considered real high tact.
Have those with you.
That was a big deal to have like an organized group of Cross Bowman because an
organized group across go Bowman could wipe out lots of people out.
We're very accurate.
The armor thing never worked out for them with all the conquistadores.
Within a few weeks they'd all fucking started wearing the Indians armor because
it's too hot.
Yeah.
Too much stuff.
They were metal and metal rots in the jungle and shitness but the Indians had
fabulous cotton textiles that made,
made,
you know,
so Columbus is,
um,
his journals,
they were all his own way of measuring the salinity,
his own way of measuring the color of the water.
So he would just describe that like that's how he knew
he'd been at sea since he was a teenager.
Genewiz tended to go to ca cause they were slave traders and there was always a
tradition of slavery in Genoa,
which is why he didn't perceive the Indians,
just people as much as his first thing he wrote back was like,
I think we found a bunch of slaves here.
You know?
Wow,
we can use these people to build stuff.
And then of course their temperament was not that way and he didn't manage any
of the situations.
Right.
And he betrayed everybody and that's why it all went so horribly shit.
And all those Indians are dead.
There's no Caribbean Indians.
It's just weird
when you stop and think about what a short amount of time ago that was.
Oh my God.
So short,
Jesus was nothing.
Two years.
500 years seems like a long time for one person.
But once you've been alive for a little while and like you're in your forties
and you start looking at you going,
you know,
that didn't take that long.
It seemed like he moved pretty quick.
How many of these are left?
How many of them do you get in the life?
My mother was 94 when she passed away.
Five of those born in 1919 yeah.
Five lives.
Birth to death.
And you're dealing with like the most horrible atrocities that you know we have
like on record,
there was times when my mother was born,
there was no,
it's so weird.
Radio Sir,
growing up in Columbus,
Ohio because that's named after Christopher Columbus.
And there's all these fucking statues everywhere,
like just like celebrating this man and you grew up in school celebrating and
it's just weird now.
Well we looked at men and not at any of reality.
Keep talking.
Should we?
Oh,
okay.
We can adjourn if you like.
I know.
Right.
And if you get to Seville,
there's a giant statue of him.
Uh,
and there's one in Barcelona chair looking out over the scene now.
And then the statue in Seville is in the cathedral and he's being carried in a
litter,
you know,
by four Indians from different tribes and they're wearing their Indian garb.
And he's in a big brass that are like that.
And his foot is rubbed completely shiny,
cause it's good luck to rub club foot in Seville was on a river.
And every year when the,
the fleet would come back to treasure fleet from the new world,
they'd be ladened down like almost to the water line with fucking gold and
precious goods and people and stuff.
And they'd come up the river and there was a chain across the river and Sybil.
And they'd pull the chain out.
And,
and it's sail up the river.
And that was a big event every year because when the treasure fleet came to
Oculus,
like,
and of course Spanish people got none of that money.
Just the crown.
And then what did they do?
Wage war against the French and the hall,
the Dutch and the English for fucking 300 years and blew all the money.
[inaudible]
you're a fucking human being.